this is the moment isil detainees
escaped from prison in northern syria
for four days isil fighters have
attempted to free their fellow members
it's unclear how many have managed to
escape
how many have been killed or recaptured
by kurdish forces who are being
supported by u.s airstrikes the prison
houses more than 1 200 prisoners from 50
different nationalities
it's seen as the most significant attack
by isil since the armed group was
defeated in the region three years ago
this footage shows isil fighters
breaking into prison
a pile of bodies dressed in uniform lay
in the corner
kurdish forces say they have the upper
hand
now daesh exists only in the prison i
mean apart from the prison they don't
exist anywhere so they are controlling
the prison only and we are surrounding
them
they do have weapons i don't deny that
but they can't do anything with that
they might run out of ammunition and
therefore they don't fight back
residents near the prison are fleeing
the fighting
there's been bombing war pains and
conflicts since yesterday and young
people were slaughtered what is
happening the situation is catastrophic
we fled the shelling in conflict we got
scared for our children and fled
there's also reports isil fighters have
broken into homes and killed people
they're slaughtering
members broken and killed four men our
neighbors two of them were brothers
[Music]
as the fighting continues the fear now
is whether this attack means a
significant return by the armed group or
a one-off attempt to replenish its
numbers for a future front against
kurdish forces assalbaig al-jazeera